gute den fall selbst seine
atomstreitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft
und hier im studio zu gast ist dr markus
vatter verteidigungspolitischer sprecher
der fdp schön dass sie hier sind ganz
ehrliche antwort macht ihnen das angst
doch das macht jedem angst wir haben den
überfall putins auf die ukraine gesehen
da hat man schon am geisteszustand
gezweifelt aber jetzt die atomwaffen in
alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen dass es
ein völlig unprovoziert schritt und da
glaube ich jeden angst wir haben gehört
von paul ronzheimer und zugeschaltet aus
kiew der ganz klar gesagt hat die
ukraine die ist davon gar nicht so sehr
überrascht wir haben immer davor gewarnt
es bleibt also die frage wann wie naiv
ich glaube die deutsche öffentlichkeit
war relativ lange naiv war man an
frieden gewöhnt war und wenn man es
nicht gewöhnt war das andere nicht so
vernünftig sind wie man selbst die
ukraine haben 1994 freiwillig ihre
atomwaffen abgegeben und russland hat im
gegenzug der ukraine die territoriale
unversehrtheit garantiert